[Music]
hey guys and thanks for tuning in to et
live look who is with us it is the cast
of famous in love bella thorne is here
carter jenkins is here charlie deputy is
here
two hours tonight guys i think we should
get right into it because some people
have already seen all 10 episodes even
though eight have already aired um
what is going to transpire between paige
and raynor and jake give us a give us a
teaser
well
you know it's kind of it's like a it's a
sort of a triangle yeah situation here
is it going to get worse or better
though tonight
it's going to be more complicated much
more complicated
explain
uh
well jake is
kind of
i feel like he's fed up with la he's fed
up with the whole lac yeah he he wants
to start working he's tired of all his
successes being pulled from him
including paige and so i think he's
ready to kind of just feel a new scene
and um
so we're gonna find out what he does i
mean he's gonna
have to make a choice whether he wants
to
stay and actually
try and work things out with paige or if
he wants to move on and go somewhere
else um
but uh yeah he's got stiff competition
so
well we actually have a little teaser of
tonight's episode it is a major peak
moment in my opinion so we are going to
play it right now are you guys ready
yeah i'm ready yeah i'm stoked i'm not
ready
will this shut down production did she
reject you she rejected you didn't she
rainer's recovery is private but i
assure you as a cast we're really
supportive of one another
um thank you but paige paige are you in
fact dating rayner devin
you two looked happy in those tmz photos
[Music]
but the triangle just gets worse tonight
so let's talk about the events leading
up to this press conference hey who do
you think that paige belongs with
before the press conference
um
yeah goodness i feel like she just
doesn't belong with either character you
know she's she's so confused and so uh
new to this and you know even though
she's at the end there before this scene
takes place she's kind of put in a
really uncomfortable position where nina
basically tells her like people like you
together stay together for press and so
even if she's not dating rainer then she
has to look like she's with him so
either way she's losing jake um so i
feel like she should just keep them both
mellow and trying to figure out her own
[ __ ] and you know concentrate for a
minute because clearly
she's very lost and does not know how to
handle these kind of situations she gets
herself into yeah and if you guys have
any questions for the cast make sure
that you're leaving them below because
we will ask them uh throughout this
conversation but what do you guys make
of the press conference interruption and
what she just said that she doesn't
belong with either
well as a
an advocate for raynor
i i think that and i respect that answer
bella but i i would make an appeal that
please quiet on the set
i just think that that you know i think
that i think that rainer and paige
belong together i don't know i do okay
have you guys talked to marlene at all
about what happens because there's quite
the cliffhanger
at the end of this episode so do you
know or can you anticipate or guess i
mean we're
at all the live tweets we're doing it's
basically it's the time where the cast
is together every week and i find that
every time we end up doing a live we
start just throwing out theories of what
we think season two is going to have and
what we think is that a season two
confirmation no it's definitely not i'm
still figuring that out um
but uh yeah i mean we're throwing around
theories i
have a lot of ideas on what i want jake
to be but i'm not a writer or i am a
writer but i'm not right on this show um
what what kind of theories
um i think that there's a whole lot
there's a lot more layers to jake that
you haven't seen um
no one they never talk about his past
they never talk about where he came from
they never like he's just this guy that
she met in college um and
he
is a writer in la and if people who live
in l.a people who understand the
entertainment industry people who watch
our show can understand that uh la and
the business is a very twisted and
political business and i think that jake
sometimes can play on the politics he
can play on the ties he plays on the
house of cards vibes a little bit yeah
um those are dark vibes yeah i think
darker than people i mean but this is
this is literally i preface this by
saying i've been told nothing like no
one says anything to me other than bella
saying one time like in like episode
three that
why is jake like when he's sleeping with
alexis um
it's true why did he why do you think
that he's supposed to do that i think he
like paige is naive but at the same time
i think he's smarter than that i think
he's naive and smart at the same time he
realizes what he's doing by uh by going
with her but um
yeah i don't know yeah the truth is that
we're we are
hanging on that cliff with the audience
we don't know yeah so you have you've
not talked to any of the writers you
haven't talked tomorrow
they just won't say anything
do you guys know when you and can
anticipate an announcement about a
season two or
i feel like bella might know have some
insight
would you
would you want to do a season two well
of course yeah no of course oh yes
there's so much growing room for our
characters to do definitely but you know
you'll hear about one
they're all they're
your mom
but keep keep keep tweeting it keep
supporting it you know to the very end
that always gets the writers and you
know the network obviously super excited
so the more we get hyped about famous
love the more famous and love you will
see okay
good point uh for bella and carter can
you guys explain in a few sentences what
exactly locked
is about
in a few sentences
actually charlie said it really well one
time he said that it's didn't you say
it's like
uh
uh the notebook with the time machine
oh that wasn't me that's i thought that
was you that said i said that it's
genius
i feel like that's what it is yeah it's
it's which is actually a great pitch for
a movie i think that
studios should
maybe warner brothers
yeah it's a great idea it's like it's an
epic love story well i think
you know for the reason they took so
long to figure it out and change it from
the book a little bit and you know
do different things with it is because
they were saying that that would be
really cool to make that movie yeah yeah
hot tub time machine meets
we already have fan questions coming in
heidi says we want a season two so maybe
not exactly a question um but a
statement d says thank you yes i agree i
agree with you we all want to season two
uh d says bella charlie and carter are
any of you guys famous in love or just
famous and single
oh
great question
okay smartly worded there
um
single like a pringle which doesn't
really make
sense because they're like in a stack of
other pringles so i don't know why but
yeah it's not interesting but yeah
just chilling guys
chilling
all three of them
we're all saying please
[Laughter]
[Music]
pretty much like a lot of cast members
on our show are single i feel like
pretty much
like
almost like for a good amount nikki
georgie
that's true
that's it yeah
yeah what's that yeah all over
them um that's a great question rick
says bella if this series was real and
you were paige who would you choose
um um
personal preference i would choose um
raynor just because i've dated somebody
that wasn't in the industry and that is
that gets really tricky and at least
with
rainer and stuff like he gets it the
paparazzi you know when when she sees
the photos of them together and she's
like oh my god he's like he he just
blows it off which is really what you
have to do so i feel like for paige to
kind of find her way in hollywood to
navigate through the right people it
would be really smart of her to have
rainer by her side because obviously um
you can see he truly does care but you
know at the same time too it's like her
and jake have that special bond that you
guys are like you know if you're not
dating or married you're best friends
till death like and that's that's
that's like a whole nother strong bond
so it's hard yeah well kind of going
back to what you said i feel like this
show really shows the hardships and the
challenges of dating and
being famous so is that something that
you guys have all struggled with or what
is the biggest
challenge of that
i mean you guys don't really need my
answer on this question
i don't i don't have those hardships i
don't have those struggles it's just
weird i i mean not for me but but like
just it's just weird to uh
i mean bella's my friend and then you
see things like photos and people are
saying things to me i'm like i don't
know and you don't know
but you know
we see pictures i don't know it's just a
strange existence was that life it
really is weird it's it's it's hard
because the paparazzi literally they
know where i live so they
literally i cannot leave the house
without a photo and it's like most of
the time i'm just chilling i'm just
hanging out like i'm not dating anybody
yeah if i want to just like go and hang
out with like i should be allowed to do
that but of course as soon as i step
outside of my house i have to take that
commitment of being like oh god well
what are people are going to say who's
going to write this about and it's just
like that makes you so unhappy
that kind of stuff if you have to think
about
doing that before every single time
you hang out with anybody guy or girl
like that is so difficult like you would
just be like you know what
forget it [ __ ] it like i don't want to
do any of this i'm just going to be a
hermit and stay in my house and never
leave because this sucks and like i just
go out of my way to be like oh
no you're not gonna do that don't make
yourself fun happy still do what you
want to do bella but it's hard yeah well
do you wish it would all go away ever
have you ever gotten to that point
because that's got to be
very hard i would imagine on the heart i
mean i feel like
with anything it's like everything has
its ups and downs so like there's so
many great things about like
that side of it in the way that it's
like somebody will see a paparazzi photo
of me where like you know i have no
makeup on my skin looks a mess and some
girl will then say to me hey by the way
the fact that you go out with your acne
and like you don't wear makeup like that
makes me so happy because now i feel
like i can do that that is amazing like
that is the part that you strive for
every day and then there's the downside
of everybody being like oh my god what
she doing but it's all just like
whatever
chilling you know i think more people
probably do appreciate that you use your
platform though to be yourself and to be
candid
and honest right i do try thank you i
think that's something one of the one of
the few girls social medias that i've
seen that what you see is what you get
and it's like
what what she posed is very much real
very much her
which isn't very common
just what i find watching you guys it
seems like you've really bonded and
gotten close
do you feel protective of each other
definitely absolutely yeah yeah we
definitely saw this that's cool
over each other
i think our whole we have a group cast
uh
text message do you really um and um
yeah we we're like we're like a family
in there mm-hmm what goes on in the
group text
keith's talking about how he wants to be
a sex symbol i'm kidding
that's true
i feel like it's a lot of it's true it's
a lot of memes it's a lot of gifts that
keith is sending him keith is just like
very very active all the time he's
hilarious yeah so funny um no but it's
just like random invites like hey is
anybody going here tonight i'm gonna be
there like you guys want to come chill
yeah
yeah
going back to the show a little bit uh
rainer's parents
and that whole revelation how is that
uh going to affect him do you think
moving forward
in tonight's episode and
season two these these last couple
episodes are
uh very very pivotal for rainer um
he you know
that's
it shakes him at his core of who he is
as a person to find out that kind of
information
it's such a betrayal by his mother to be
lied to his whole life about who his
father is
i felt
i felt for rainer
and um i don't know what will happen
going forward
but his life is is a mess and i think
that's when he
reaches out to paige and and she's there
for him
you know yeah
i feel like on the show there's a lot of
hard issues that are tackled between
family drama and sobriety and jealousy
maybe what's the hardest thing that you
guys have all had to go through in
hollywood
as individuals
well i i'm
i feel like what's interesting about
being an actor and and having any
success is that it really doesn't take
away
issues that everyone goes through in
their lives whether it be familial or
relationships or you know whatever we
still have those those
um hardships yeah and sometimes they can
be magnified but if you know bella's
situation by
paparazzi and all that stuff and being
in the public eye
but um
yeah i mean we've i'm sure we've all
been through all that stuff yeah i mean
i think one obstacle that's i feel is
pretty unique to hollywood i mean it's
my brother's a firefighter and he had to
go through something similar because
it's harder to be a firefighter than
getting to harvard apparently but uh i
i've seen that one obstacle is
definitely rejection uh actors face an
extreme amount of rejection uh and that
sometimes the success doesn't seem like
a success like you'll go to test for a
big big project
and
well yes that's a mini success uh at the
end of the day if you didn't book the
job it's close to no cigar yeah um and
so
actors that is just like part of the job
and so that's peppy says this a lot but
it's like that's why you have to love it
so much because if you don't love the
job
when you
don't book it you're just going to be
faced with disappointment after
disappointment after disappointment
rather than opportunity after
opportunity after opportunity so um
but every actor deals with it
differently i mean it's but it's
definitely hard it's definitely not easy
well said well so truly thanks charlie i
need advice that you would give to kids
who maybe want to get into acting they
want to be famous
um if you
want to be famous and you want to get
into acting those are two different
things and it's best if you don't try to
mix them um
if you want to be famous then like you
know i feel like it's cool if you want
to be famous to be famous for like
something that's awesome or like you
know you're such a humanitarian that you
know you're famous because of this
people want to follow you on instagram
because they want to see all the great
work you're doing for bullying or
children or you know whatever it is you
want to be an actor you know be an actor
but um you know also be an actors actor
every time you're sitting in that chair
waiting for that audition you're so
nervous and you're like i hope i get it
i hope i get it
every person next to you is thinking the
same exact thing you know like don't
i've seen a lot of actors give other
actors especially in audition rooms and
stuff like that like shade and i'm just
like guys
like come on everybody's here trying the
same thing doing the same job like you
know
rehearsing this wanting it whatever we
all want the same thing so like my
goodness people be an actor's actor
always stick up for your actors always
you know work well with other actors
keep an open mind at any time that
you're acting i feel like a lot of
people have echoed that same exact
sentiment like they've come here and
they've been like oh yeah it's so hard i
feel like you get bullied or i feel like
you get picked on or whatever it is and
you were open about that a couple years
ago about a hollywood mean girl and then
in this show you have alexis who's
pretty harsh is that something that you
guys all still deal with i think it's no
matter what you do in your life
it is that it is high school whether
it's college or you have a job or you
work at a firm or whatever like there's
always you know those people that want
to get up so bad that they have to
actually stomp their way up there and
not just like step
nicely
they stomp it
so um i feel like that's in anything you
do no matter what job you have in life
there's a difference i feel like as you
as you grow up and and you know move
past high school and all that you you
start to realize exactly that that those
people
are are only trying to make you feel
small so they can feel bigger
and if you ever feel less than
that it's not you it's your environment
it's the people around you that are
telling you a story you're choosing to
believe
it's not true
yeah yeah i think uh in in hollywood
rather than the alexis mean girl type
like that while they do exist i think
the majority of that that you see comes
in
um
just like an overall fake attitude it's
like they use diplomatic acting skills
to try and rise to go up the ladder make
friends with people who they really
don't care about
but they're actors so they can fake it
that is i think much more common that's
gonna be a hard part about fame too is
knowing who you can trust
in kind of that same vein
oh yeah that's [ __ ] difficult
like no matter what you're always still
figuring that out problem is with me or
it's not necessarily a problem but i
notice it often is like
i'll be i'll give you so many chances
even if i see something sketchy or i see
a red fire i'm like why did you just do
that you know and then i just i'm like
oh you know it could have been this and
it could have been mad and it's fine and
it's fine until it's like not fine and
it's blown up in my face and then i'm
like oof bella why did you and then even
after that point i'll literally be like
ah i'm mad about it for five minutes you
know what come here give me a hug it's
fine whatever i'm over it and then i'm
like bella what are you doing to
yourself is that because you want to see
the good in people
um
yeah because like no matter what if if
you're going through something or like
what i always say about bullying is like
you have
you feel bad that you're being bullied
yes but also try and feel bad for the
bully because whoever is doing something
like that with those type of intentions
is actually being
so hurt like at the same time there has
to be something that's happening at home
or that's happening here or you know
something that they've experienced
that's that's irking them so bad that to
feel better about it they have to put
somebody else down or else they are
going to sink themselves um and so i
always like to think of it like that
like
i mean i get it like i can get it that's
not how i would do it or that's not how
i would be but
like at the same time i can't say that i
don't i don't understand it i do yeah
we're gonna take a few more fan
questions because my phone right here is
kind of blowing up
um jasmine says team jake
uh
ricardo says bella when is your song
just call coming out oh yeah let's go
let's go
[Music]
goodness i have spent the last four days
recording so much music and i'm like
this is like the most i've recorded
music in like
ever i feel like ever like i've
literally
yesterday or was it yeah
no okay so the day before yesterday i
was at the studio yesterday but for
something else then the day before i was
literally with this producer dan like
literally
i'm not kidding you like 13 hours like
we were literally we recorded three
songs and wrote another one are you
writing all your own music right now no
i like to um
mix in my [ __ ] with like a lot of
different people just because i like
different sounds of music um
i have like songs with you know i have
something with borgore and i have you
know
that just call and then i have more
acoustic sad [ __ ] that i wrote and then
i have like some other rock stuff i have
some hip hop stuff with other different
people
i can't wait for your acoustics that
[ __ ]
i feel like you'll be like it's not i
wouldn't say it's necessarily sad it's
more like
mad yeah
it's pretty bad
wait what's inspiring the the angry sad
music
i just um
i well okay so so well
the idea of the song is like i'm done um
i i listen to a lot of songs that's like
oh you're breaking me and then like
after that that you're like you know
it's chill whatever i'm all good after
this or it's just falling in love but
you don't hear the mid part which is
like you know what after you've broke me
i was sad but now i'm just like i'm done
which is what the song is called as i'm
done and and at that point in your life
when you get to that point where you're
like you know what i'm oh i'm so done
with this whole [ __ ] scenario like
forget about it dude
i can't wait for the new bellathorn
stuff but i'm always gonna be a fan of
the old stuff
do we have one
no he's trying he's searching um
a few more
just says i'm so obsessed with this show
um cheyenne this pains me to ask you
this um what happened with scott disick
and how old were you when you met him
how old was i
because i haven't known him for that
long
i've been the same age
um
and um i'm sorry what was the question
what happened with scott disick um
what do you mean that's like a very
blatant question like like what is this
like give me more like i i don't what do
you mean what happened we're chill
we're chilling
we're friends we're cool
um
i literally just saw him so yeah like
it's all chill um
i don't know what answer you want me to
do
but i'm guessing it's something
and you're not getting it
all right cheyenne
um diane says bella be honest who's a
better kisser charlie or carter
that is terrible whoa what is this why
do you guys gotta make things a
competition we'll close our eyes and you
just point out one another
no i'm not doing this that is so
terrible
that's great these are just different
yeah
let's talk about your evolution on this
show and also in hollywood i feel like
we love seeing your fashion change so
what's kind of inspiring your choices
lately oh my goodness i heard you say
that you were gonna dye your hair pink
oh yes i i i did i was keeping that a
secret but now all you guys know
what up i'm dying my hair pink tonight
soon oh tonight yeah okay tonight uh me
and my sister are doing it we're just
gonna lather it on because my hair is so
light i got these thick ass extensions
in when i like let my hair out it's like
big and like poofy so it'll be like
like pink with like really ultra
different pink vibes and poofy and then
after i'm done with these guys i'm just
gonna take them out and i'm gonna have
like my regular hair which is like down
to here um and just do pink until i go
back into red that's kind of fun yeah
it is i i love changing up like i love
doing different stuff especially like
i like to do it all while i have a
minute so because i'm allowed right now
and nobody's like
you can't do it then like i like gotta
do like three different hair colors in
like
three months but for my style it really
just depends on like the group crew that
like i'm going out with me and lo we're
just talking about this um and just like
it depends like sometimes i go super
dark and you're like whoa like
she showed up dark today and i got like
these huge creeper like moon boots on
and i'm just like fishnets and i'm like
looking super dark and then other times
are just like this which is more on like
the rare occasion um and then i just
yeah i just have very different styles
but like in each thing that i wear even
if it's like more cleaned up looking and
like oh i look more classy today i still
have like my weird little quirks like
with like my mismatching socks and stuff
so it's still always like me
i saw on your twitter that you are vying
to take home the teen choice award for
best snapchatter guys how do we get her
to win how do we get you to win i love
snapchat i mean
the tweets that i get about my snapchat
as well
is like you guys are so sweet about the
snap i know so like when i walk down the
street sometimes it's so crazy i'll get
like the most random not my fan base
like people that'll come up to me like
i i follow you on snap i just watched
your story like this is so weird like
oh my god your snapchat is awesome and
i'm always like wow that is my most
favorite compliment one of them
definitely because like my instagram is
me yes and like my twitter is like you
know me
um but my snapchat is just really the
most me um and i'm always posting on i'm
always doing weird [ __ ] i'm waxing and
i'm doing this and i'm doing that and
you know um so it's like if you watch my
snapchat you literally
you're like one of my friends really
like you get what everybody else gets so
that's always like a huge compliment for
me because i'm like you actually like me
do you guys watch your snapchats yep
they're kind of they're amazing
like they're very candid and very open
anything that you won't post on snapchat
um
um
i have to like be choosy of course um
because obviously like well like
sometimes i'll take a pic where i'm like
oh
damn b like
yes you work it out
and i'll like want to post it because
i'll be like you know i like this photo
and then other times i'll be like uh is
it too
like
but for the most part you question that
i can't fix i feel like you are so good
about posting just you and what you want
to post what yeah i mean i do
i'm like i never it's really rare that
i'm like
wait no i'm not i'm actually not going
to because like if i'm pulling out my
phone to take a photo obviously
i know if it's on snapchat that i'm
gonna want to post it on my story so
like i'm not gonna
like even think about doing something
that i wouldn't post but i'm pretty sure
like i don't know one thing i do that i
wouldn't post on snapchat i pretty i
feel like i literally i post everything
yeah
i saw you posted a picture of you guys
reading twitter together
yeah do you guys actually go through and
read all the comments and all the tweets
about the show and about you guys yeah
it's really fun yeah and it's actually
you responding yeah
yeah we do all of our own social media
platforms what's your favorite kind of
comment to get
team jake
team rainer
yeah i like rage i like i i that's
something i didn't really think about
when we shot the show yeah like that
that ship name
i i guess it's in the book and
everything i shouldn't think of it as
the thing and then that kind of caught
on and then this whole thing caught and
there's an emoji of that and so i i just
i really enjoyed seeing how people
um
you know responded to that relationship
the jade emoji would just be like a
deformed hand
well tonight on social media do we think
that we're gonna get more team jake or
more team rainer tweets i mean honestly
i feel like okay so in my opinion a lot
of the reason of why everybody's so like
rage is because
jake's character hasn't shown
enough like he he doesn't let paige see
his vulnerable side he doesn't and like
when we were talking about it when we
were filming it i was like why would she
choose jake at this point like he's
being so mean to her like like you know
and he's just like not even dealing with
her at all and so of course as like you
know fans you're gonna be like oh well
of course i like
rage then together but when jay comes in
in that last scene and like gives me
everything lays his whole heart on the
table for literally the whole world to
see and choose what they want to do with
his heart if they want to embarrass him
or if they want to make light of it or
whatever they want and he he he takes
that option and he's committed to it
right there in that scene and i feel
like
that scene of course people are going to
be like oh damn well i don't know he's
really nice too like
now i really don't know i was i was rage
before and now i'm kind of jade and now
i just feel like can they all just date
all three
um have fun before you guys go like how
fun was that to shoot because you have
all the media going crazy you have him
bursting in
i felt bad
honestly i felt bad for you because you
have such a monologue in that scene and
so because there's so many people the
coverage sitting from just our side we
started our side yeah so he's saying
these lines all
day and the camera hasn't turned around
uh no i don't know
everyone is fast no but what i would say
is that i would say the hardest part
about shooting that scene was i run in
from the back doors and it's like it's a
rather like superman yeah yeah
it's a rather it's like a tight angle so
it's like the the way the camera starts
makes it look like the entrance is
closer than it is it's like a 40 or 50
yard hallway and i was like yesterday
every take i'm like
wait paige don't answer that so it's
like it was uh it was but it was it was
so much fun yeah my parents came for
that and so that was really cool because
that was the only time they came to that
i would let them um
but yeah it was uh it was a fun it was a
fun scene to shoot it was cool because
like for once i because we finally had
like us three in a scene and
me and you connecting we shot that on
the same day like right before
the scene leading up to this one um and
so that was really nice because
obviously you're like oh like that was a
good scene for like yeah i'd like our
characters together and then you run in
and then you say
all this and your character's so
courageous and charming that you're like
now personally i'm like oh
but then he's got like the and then i'm
looking at him and i'm just like hmm
this is hard for paige i could see how
she's getting herself in a little bit of
a pickle here hard choices
uh well thank you guys for tuning in
make sure that you watch the two hour
finale tonight on freeform at 9pm and
keep up with carter charlie and bella
all on social media are you guys going
to be live tweeting tonight are you guys
gonna be interacting with the fans yeah
yeah use hashtag famous and love chat uh
that's the best way we'll be able to
hear from you and talk with you guys and
uh we usually do so yeah awesome and
make sure that you like et's facebook
page and we'll see you next time
[Music]